se conocieron los resultados de una
tercera autopsia en el caso de de baní
escobar la joven de 18 años desaparecida
cuando regresaba a su casa de una fiesta
el pasado 9 de abril en monterrey que la
causa de muerte de evans y susana
escobar basaldúa se debió a una asfixia
por sofocación en su variedad de
obstrucción de orificios respiratorios
el caso se convirtió en un escándalo
nacional por las múltiples
incongruencias de las autoridades
tardaron casi dos semanas en encontrar
su cuerpo en el tanque de un motel
cercano a la carretera donde fue vista
por última vez e inicialmente sugirieron
que escobar murió por una contusión
después de caer por error al pozo pero
una segunda autopsia realizada por
investigadores privados contratados por
la familia de bani concluyó que había
sido agredida sexualmente
versión que también fue negada en esta
tercera revisión tras exhumar el cuerpo
la tercera conclusión es el hecho de que
no se encontró ninguna evidencia ningún
tipo de lesión hallazgo que pudiera
sustentar violencia sexual
y la última es que se descarga por
completo la posibilidad de una asfixia
por sumersión en medio de las
incongruencias su padre ha sido una
figura importante en los
cuestionamientos en una búsqueda de
justicia queremos decirles mi esposa y
yo
que seguimos
buscando la verdad como comentaba el
fiscal
que seguimos en la lucha
de saber qué fue lo que le pasó a dedo
ni
la historia de the bank ya escobar se
sumó una serie de otras desapariciones
en la región que provocaron protestas en
todo méxico donde se estima que 10
mujeres son asesinadas cada día